salut les menthe à l'eau aujourd'hui on
résout le casse tête de la maison de
doha car elle déménage pour ceux ci j'ai
un invité de marque s'appelle fabien
olicard mais non mais moi j'aime bien et
ans loïc derrière la caméra en fait donc
l'invité de marc faber lucas au
bienvenue fabien ben écoute merci de
m'avoir invité sur ma chaîne saint
pierre quiberon aussi alors aujourd'hui
on va résoudre un casse tête
ok c'est la maison de doha qui déménage
donc de son vrai nom déménagement facile
merci d'être là le hic c'est lui qui
vous montent au cas où vous connaissez
pas encore loïc les vidéos qui sort tous
les mercredis à 6 heures du matin et
d'autres vidéos
en clair je n'ai pas encore essayé il
est considéré comme très difficile
on verra si c'est le cas ou pas mais on
a cette boîte il faut que tout ça ça
rentre dans la boîte et que ce soit plat
quoi qu'il dépasse s'accorde un
déménagement est ce qu'on a déjà
déménagé
non non je ne suis jamais allé je suis
né droit ou même rester à cet endroit là
mais c'est laisser la base sissach pas
s'embêter
j'habite à la maternité je l'invite à la
maternité d'ailleurs d'un 12e chambre
602 dans le 12e chambre sur s'ils
voulaient venir me voir il n'y a pas de
débat d'il y a pas beaucoup d'espacé
confessionnelles écoute moi je propose
d'être pragmatique à savoir que moi j'ai
envie de compter le nombre de cubes et
le nombre de tubes possible la rentrée
pour voir si est-ce qu'il faut que ça
s'imbriquent pile poil tu as commencé à
tetris ou est-ce qu'on peut laisser de
l'air ok confiance contre l'autre
moi je conquois ouais ouais alors du
coup c'est cette affaire caf
donc ça fait lui
quoique à 32 et donc la tata compte et
ça fait combien les petits cubes ça fait
a eu droit qu'à 32 et du coup j'ai pas
du tout quoi d'accord je suis un gars 22
bah ouais 9 10 à 20 21 22
tu avais hasard coïncidence génie je
n'ai pas envie de répondre à cette
question mais je ne vous mets un sondage
donc vas-y en commençant sur le banc une
phase d'exploration bien exploré la
alors vraiment au pouvoir que la boîte
carrée solide solidement fait toft les
relativement car et c'est ce qui en fait
ils contrôlent en même temps la caméra
d'ici vous mettre la turquie tous soient
nés en fin sur le plan parce que des
fruits bah je vais faire je commence
simple on note de l'âge de voir passer
ce parce que ça c'est triste parce que
ça c'était triste pas quoi on chante là
ça me fait un trou en dessous mais à
partir du moment où je me dis qu'il ya
quand même moins deux carrés que de
volume
la possible 22 carré pour 30 de pub
possible je pense que ça s'emboîte
paille qui va y avoir l'air à droite à
gauche jacques la part de sherbrooke
dans un espace comme ceci je n'aurais
pas une pièce comme cela je suis assez
d'accord avec toi
oui en fait c'est sensé tours couverts
c'est ça après on pourrait poser une
feuille d'or où on pourrait bloquer tu
en auras pas mais est-ce qu'il y aura
des trous dedans
bah je pense non mais sincèrement je
veux dire en dessous alors la surface
frappe sera vraiment jours ferme et
femmes ah bah alors déjà je sais pas je
les reçus avec tout en pâte est comme ça
dedans tu sais ce que ça me rappelle sa
logique
dis moi fabien savoir que ça te rappelle
me rappelle quand j'essaye de faire mes
valises en tournée parce que je sais pas
si tu sais mais je suis en tournée en ce
moment avec nous c'est la wii mais je
suis va où là ce mois ci par exemple
vous pouvez me retrouver en moselle mais
également à marseille également à dijon
les tout le reste des villes et ces
villes là vous les avez dans la
description dans le lien vers mons et je
peux aussi un bon bah oui c'est
j'attendais quand même que parce que moi
j'ai tu vois tu commence comme ça je
peux moi je pense que les trucs d'angle
sont peut-être fait pour les gens c'est
rien en mai dans les angles
j'essaierai quand même de faire plein de
trucs tous les couleurs c'est un rapport
c'est pour ça oui c'est de l'art mais
pourquoi ça entrerait pas ça va
j'avais une idée qui ne fonctionne pas
ah oui parce qu'en fait ça fait pas
exactement quatre carrés d'un certain
manque de buzz on est c'est fou à quel
point les casse tête c'est fait pour
faire chier quand même pas deux il ya
pas de voie là j'aurais fait ça aussi
non mais je sais pas je me dis on n'a
pas fait trop d'espacé reste il reste un
cube et du dr lammens pour vous faire en
bas tu sens on peut biaiser en soirée
moi je pense que ça va être un peu
obligatoire
c'est ce que c'est ce côté traité
christian nique à tous et oui et ça ça
c'est vraiment nous émerveiller de la
vie vérité dans la soirée chaste
ça fait vraiment bizarre quand tu fais
ça quand il est placé lundi de pas aller
acheter car si je pas perdu de l'espace
avec ça
tu étais pas en géométrie content
faisait quand jean thissen l'espace ben
pas du tout mais on peut jouer on peut
faire ça comme ça en ce moment
genre à l'extérieur ben voilà c'est
comme ça arriver oui il suffit de faire
une boîte plus petit mais surtout élevé
de pièces parce qu'il ya des certes pas
tellement c'était les pièces de rechange
tasser les capacités au cas où on en
avait la garde et une clairement on a
beaucoup trop de place du coup il ya un
côté teubé on veut céder donc si on sait
que ça marchera pas mais on imagine sa
marche du temps mais ça c'est les mêmes
pièces en fait je pense vraiment qu'il
ya une espèce de symétrie à maintenir
écoute j'ai essayé parce que je vois que
c'est assez je vais aller aux toilettes
mais ok et bien quand je reviens c'est
une des toilettes ne sont pas ici du
tout du coup je vais aller plus
tardivement que c'est gratuit si tu
finis
c'est vrai six filles c'est ouf j'ai
très tentés de regarder la réponse est
plus sur internet juste plus pour me la
péter mais quoi non je disais ce serait
c'est si j'avais une réponse je ne serai
pas tenté
les sikhs et sinon ça va bien ça va
ok c'est frustrant parce que j'ai
l'impression d'avoir les trottoirs et
oui justement mais j'étais en train de
défaire pour que tu puisse leur faire
toi même comme ça tu vas mieux pour toi
il ya ça qui bloque et sa osier du
boulot ouais mais là ça je l'avais vue
là c'est tout à l'heure voilà non mais
j'ai réfléchi quand même qu'on a apporté
autant d'aller regarder la réponse sur
internet
je pense en vrai qu'on ne peut même pas
la trouver ce que je pense que si tu
tapes déménagement facile
oui c'est bon tu vois suivre je pense
que la tentation serait oui ouais par
exemple d alors et des foires été tenté
et des fois était pas inventé lui tu
vois ça c'est pas mal par exemple je
sais pas si c'est bien tu es la honte
oui si on perd demain mais si on met jeu
les filles c'est bon natha finirait
alors je sais que les caisses d'ici de
vote là mais je pense je te le promets
que je pense avoir terminé
il faut pas forcer alors non non mais je
ne sais pas je sais où tu regardes là
bas regarde là bas je leur fais voir
pour vérifier la solution bon donc ça
marche ça fonctionne ouais et c'est bien
lisse au bout c'est déjà 10 ans là c'est
le 20e titre est ce que tu veux tu as
regardé sur cet écran non non non parce
que c'est ça d'écran c'est ça ouais mais
j'ai vraiment pas vous regarder je te
crois pas tellement mais vas-y vas-y
fall est ok je les mets donc 7 dollars
ces deux là c'est allé placer layrac et
une gracq blâme
pikit charles blé goudé à kiev
spécialisé depuis 1956 c'est pas mal du
tout ça fait moins bien sinon mieux non
je porte
notamment parce que tu me proposer là
par exemple je commence à me dire tiens
il n'a pas regardé l'écran ça si ça ça
va là clairement ça j'ai pas dit latvala
voilà et ce qui est génial c'est que
rien ne le choque parce que en vrai
voilà on va faire le même mouvement
point que tout à l'heure ça passe
ou alors comme ceci aussi bien toi mais
ça c'est une petite résistance à ce
niveau là tu es déjà dix ans ceci dans
les trucs qu'on chope vous en poule et
les allumettes que ça fait des
résistances mais plus rien à fait
sincère des bons en maintenant une
résistance qui devraient et puis avec
les sept partis au beau jeu
ah ben voilà et si aucune résistance
j'ai envie de dire tout seul tout seul
comme un legs de faire des passes
bertone heureusement que je suis fort
dans ce type du coup je me regarde bien
cette forme
non plutôt le haut puisque maintenant
refaire en speed ouais carrément babar
exemple le lien de la boîte et dans la
description si vous voulez le voir si
vous voulez voir de bottes
d'ailleurs on soit hors froid or c'est
cette boîte là heureusement ce duke quoi
samedi si ça vous dit vous avez dit de
l'aide dans les commentaires et après si
ça vous dit pas on reste quand même de
refaire un parce qu'on a très envie mais
peut-être un truc base et moins sur
l'album et ris parce que steve jobs est
en fête avec un terrien mais il n'y a
pas à des buts de ce qu'on a fait tout à
l'heure mais si mais non non mais tu
sais pourquoi parce que parfois il ya
d'autres moyens de le faire
moi je te propose le lien créé dans la
description tu vas tu on verra aussi
d'autres casse-tête en choisit une
courte voudrait qu'on passe tous les
deux où on achète deux fois le même et
on se marre mario kart mais des cas du
casse tête mais on me coupe un bras et
on voit la vie afin de faire demain ok
bah bah c'est pas rien fait pas et bien
si vous voulez ce casse tête c'est je
les garde plus maintenant j'allais finir
je devrais je l'aimais un oui non mais
ça en vrai là c'est pas du tout pour
leur faire c'est plonger en fin de nuit
ce que j'aime bien rangée et je vous
mets une photo sur instagram que vous
retrouvez juste juste là et vous
commenter la photo pour participer au
concours est dans une semaine je fais de
carrasso sort pour ça il a gagné 5 à 6
qu'est ce que tu as fait lever c'est
fini nous coûte parce que c'est encore
meilleur mais je la fais
mais si kraft à bien toute façon je vais
te dire quelque chose il n'y a plus de
place sur la carte de la hausse de 6 est
bon à temps je le termine après geste
après la guerre il ya un truc yves
voilà si c'est bon et il a réussi vous
pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne de loïc
c'est mon visage mais je vous jure c'est
sa chaîne à lui il n'y a pas de problème
et si je vous met la vidéo de la semaine
dernière c'était la free willy à très
bientôt mercredi 6h du matin au plus
tard au revoir